what five things does the screenplay
have to have to make you interested in
being a producer for it
five things a screenplay has to have to
make me feel interested for one like I
said emotional response like I need to
know how I feel after I read it if I
feel like what was I supposed to feel
now that you got to go back to your
drawing board
so yes you have to know the feeling the
feeling needs to be there some something
some type of feeling at the end of it
the other thing is a true identity and
what genre it is and if not it's okay
cuz I can I can do that I can help with
that but if the person doesn't know what
genre they're in it's not that you have
to play by the rules but you need to
know the rules before you break them and
they're telling me oh I just made this
awesome horror film and I'm like this is
hilarious like we just watch it and
horror and comedy can intertwine but
it's like you're gonna break a rule here
let me make sure this is what you meant
by this like so I need to have a really
strong identity in its genre
another thing it needs to have is
somebody that either I can't say rooting
for but someone that a mass audience
like most people can connect with we're
in a time where you know people are a
little bit more open to different things
so I think that's that's something that
we're kind of having to like test the
the thermometer on like where are we as
a culture like what is now accepted or
whatever but you have a good idea just
from living life and watching the news
like what people accept or scroll
through the social media you could get
an idea of how they connect with things
and how they they see things so if I
have no one in that film that I see
myself in there's a problem because I
can see myself in a lot of ways I'm very
versatile I don't think I'm like this
person that has to only see this and
only see that so if I don't see
something that I can connect with we're
missing something so a connection to a
character doesn't any main character but
it can actually to a character in a way
that brings a person in we're like okay
that could be my buddy yeah I would say
that too or whatever if it's so far off
in like overly avant-garde or artsy I
just need to be told then this is what
that's supposed to be and then alright
great you want to make it here's a
little teeny budget and I'll help you
get into
weird festivals like you know if they're
like no I want this to be on every you
know like well we can't work together
because that's not gonna work so yeah as
long as as long as it has someone that
connect connect to and actually actually
kind of brought me to the other point
the first thing I asked a person before
we even read their script is where do
you see this going and that kind of
tells me and it's funny someone's always
like oh I never thought of that and I'm
like yeah you have to know where you're
going to know how to do it you have to
know where you're going to know where to
move and we're to focus on and we're
two-faced so if they don't know where
this if they wanted to go that's gonna
make my job a little harder now I can
read it and we let booths this can do
this but at least let me know where you
see it and then when I'm reading it I
can kind of say yeah you got it or you
don't and are you fine with not having
that you would have this outcome are you
good with that yeah you know I am great
or no I'm not well you're gonna have to
go back to this rewrite it have much
less location so we get you a bigger
star because this thing is not gonna
sell you know like something like that
so yes a good I guess that would be
direction a good focus point of where
they wanted to go that helps me and then
I guess for number five it has to be
relevant to the immediate culture that
doesn't mean it needs to be happening
but just relevant for instance I think
some movies that were so good that
didn't do well it was like if they just
waited a couple more years it would have
worked because we were moving to that
but this guy has a very strong opinion
on it this director or this writer or
whatever so if he's gonna come with this
opinion it's gonna kind of disconnect
and people are not gonna spread it or
find answers you're not gonna get down
with it or you know the distributor
won't readily just open the door they'll
probably throw it on Netflix somewhere
and bury it or whatever it's because
they just it was such a good project
such a good story but it just wasn't
time for it yet and I think for
producers they have to be very mindful
of that it's not just keeping up with
current events it's kind of just talking
to people and making sure that you're in
a very diverse group of people I think
every producer if you're only talking to
your buddies from school it's a problem
you need to talk to people from
different backgrounds
different financial backgrounds
different races different ethnicity
everything you need to expand your
horizons travel when you go to even if
you just travel a state over go to like
don't go to Applebee's
but like eat Applebee's when you're home
but if you're in another place go to
like the little mom-and-pop and just
kind of sit at a diner and talk to some
people because I'm thinking wow this is
such a great idea I go to Montana these
people will never watch this
so what's okay that's not it's but I got
to keep that in mind so if I'm not I
have no idea what's going on I think
like even with the political culture
right now people I didn't know people
thought like this I'm like I did it I
toured all the country doing merchandise
events like I believe me this is nothing
new but it's like that's necessary when
you're the person a producer that is is
in a position to choose what stories are
made or choose which stories you're
going to push through or find financing
for choose the right ones for the time
until the person if it's not ready they
might fight you on it you might lose a
project and they might do it anyway and
then you'll see that they you were right
but if you communicate in a way a person
can get down with it and then providers
just know like while you're writing let
yourself run free but also be aware of
what's happening around you and that
doesn't mean your idea can't happen you
just might need to adjust it so it's
like they're little you know like sugar
with the medicine type of thing like a
little bit of sugar just a low sugar in
it so it's a little bit more palatable
for where we're at that way we can
spread it to the world and everyone can
see your art but if you're staying in
this space and you're futuristic and you
have this whole idea where we're going
like okay let's now we got an atom or
budget and make a futuristic then it
can't be now because we're not there yet
or whatever so yeah being very mindful
of what's happening what the culture is
and seeing when I'm reading that script
can someone accept this as truth right
now and you do it always be a couple
knows and you got to know who those noes
are but if it's multi yeses all right we
can now move forward do you also go to
movie theaters in other in your travels
to in towns where the industry is not
prevalent or it's not a big city and
this is like the main focus of the town
like there's nothing else to do here
I do I go to a lot of movies that in a
town where there is nothing else to do
but movies and I mean nothing like in
the middle of nowhere
and it's very interesting their take on
things and I like especially in those
areas right after the film those people
talk the most they will give you the ins
and outs and I learned this by seeing it
but I also learned it from somebody that
we don't like to talk about right now
but Harvey Weinstein he established
something where he would put in a strip
mall a random in the middle of Jersey
where nobody goes anywhere but the
movies and to like the club like in the
club as a pub right like he put he would
use that theater as his litmus test so
he would put it for it for an audience
there would be nobody else around me who
just had them judge it and he would
literally stop production or not go
forward because of that little weird
little town and if Harvey Weinstein is
horrible his integrity is but the man
was genius when it came to business and
how things work and how they get things
made and sold things that weren't
necessarily the most popular thing if he
can do that I can at least go sit in the
theater and watch how the audience
reacts to it even though they're not the
people that were talking to the most
because they're gonna give you some
information you'll never heard about
I've said in a movie theater just
recently inviting Pennsylvania which is
like the middle of nowhere but also I
went it was somewhere in Tennessee and I
can't remember the area but these people
they'll stay outside the movie theater
for an hour you don't get that in a city
don't like that was nice and they're out
you so you don't really get its much
talking even in India in India ters in a
city they leave much quicker what I'm
saying I was sitting with my popcorn
just listening him talk and Scott does
this a the director I work with he
actually goes and talks to them and ask
them questions and he brings me back
information I didn't hear before because
his questions kind of sparked it so
everyone in like a my team my production
company the audacity we kind of have
that mentality like hey go to the movies
please like my goal eventually is to
make sure everyone on my on my staff has
a MCA list like you can go see three
movies a week without worrying about the
cost like it's like you know these
companies have gym memberships they give
it to the employees how they give you it
here go watch movies that's something I
want to do so encourage them go to the
movies take time off to do that because
it's necessary but also don't just leave
after say for the credits of course we
respect our industry but then also list
and stay in the lobby a little bit see
what people are saying because that
teaches us far more than Film School and
audience teaches us because that's what
we're that's what we're here for we're
here for the audience so how can you
really communicate to an audience with
this idea that you have a vision but you
you've never really heard an audience
respond to something that you know what
you thought the response would be let's
hear them out no matter how obscure
their area is no matter how city they
are how cool they are like those guys
that we're like the mom jeans
those are the guys you want to hear
respond about your little indie like
that's the guys gonna tell you some
truth so yeah listen to him to everyone
listen to everyone
you